in a new sign that americans are ready
to move on from the pandemic more people
traveled by air over the weekend than at
any point since the crisis began
it comes as the u.s set a new record
friday for vaccinations
with more than 4 million in a single day
more than 106 million americans have
received at least one dose
that's 40 percent of the adult
population health officials are
concerned though that we're loosening
restrictions
too fast potentially causing another
spike
errol barnett is at newark liberty
international airport era errol what's
the advice for travelers
well anthony the advice remains if you
can
refrain from air travel but judging on
the traffic we're seeing here at this
terminal this morning and the millions
of people
who traveled this weekend many people
just cannot refrain they have to get out
many folks heading back now
after seeing friends and family for the
easter weekend and this comes
just as the cdc issues new guidance for
people who are vaccinated you don't have
to self quarantine
or test before you fly but the major
caveat here is it still advises against
international travel
and non-essential domestic trips in san
jose california
kathy anderson reunited with her
daughter for the first time
in a year i love you too
anderson is one of the millions of
americans who returned to the skies this
weekend
shattering pandemic travel records
increased demand
prompted delta airlines to temporarily
open up middle seats
and americans domestic bookings are at
90 percent of pre-pandemic levels
it just seems like all of a sudden it's
a rush larry perez says he felt more
comfortable flying because he'd been
fully vaccinated
he's one of the 61 million americans
roughly one-fifth of u.s
adults who fall in that category we know
for vaccinated people it's reasonably
safe to do this but among unvaccinated
people it is not yet
and i'm worried that it's going to lead
to unfortunately more infections and
more hospitalizations
dr ashish jar says decreased testing
relaxation of public health measures
and new variants are now contributing to
the spread of covid
in several states it really is a race
right now between these variants that
have become widespread and are spreading
much more effectively and quickly and
how many people we can protect through
vaccines the variant initially detected
in the uk
now accounts for about 26 percent of
covert cases in the u.s
and this weekend officials announced a
new variant
initially identified in india was found
in the bay area
it's actually just made up of a couple
of other variants that we've seen
elsewhere the data so far suggests that
it may be more contagious
like the uk variant is
now as scary as that sound jar says that
the vaccine
vaccines do appear effective against the
variants and more americans are getting
these shots all of that
not just encouraging news for everyone's
health but for the travel
industry which has been battered by the
pandemic the
hotel and leisure sector added 280 000
jobs during the pandemic
but gail the unemployment rate is still
twice the national average
at 13 so positive signs but a long way
to go
yeah very positive signs i love a good
airport hug but you're right
unemployment not so great thank you
errol good to see you